foreign
[Music]
way
wait wait
go go
I was eight years old when I left there
you want me to drive no I'll drive
figure out how to put it in backwards
tickets until Monday
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
met a girl fell in love that girl died
but then she came back
came back in totaled dick oh please he
left out some important information but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
all this
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
want to make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to if I decide my friends
incinerate them
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
are you ready for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
and beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
just never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
[Music]